tomando este artigo provável que seja
agregado aí tem lá pensando se de gente
manda pelo desafio aqui se é tão bom
tempo por isso aqui virou uma fila de
casamento raciocínios clássico o bandido
vagabundo nesta quinta com renato vai
fazer um casamento de luxo sem nenhum
dinheiro para primeira coisa da lista da
china da noite que vai ficar lenta
boni que tiveram a 25 de março e tem
cupim o papai pinheiro o roubo foi na
busca com as colheres questão
perturbadora pública é tudo salvo e meu
nome é também dançou o senhor vitória é
um prazer recebendo na nossa degustação
étnica nós temos aqui um ano e cinco é
uma bebida que você vai sentir um calor
na base do tubo da goiaba chefe mundo a
microsoft deu detalhes e não falo pelo
amor de deus para o cuspe cima da comida
neste instante serve aos milhões amigos
respirar
[Música]
de qual era
a gente não tem grana pra pagar suborno
do dia é o la pucha a noivinha está
prestes a descobrir o plano
que a situação está pecuária
quer dizer pecado não é esse o saco vai
rapaz eo fotógrafo ou câmera 4 cada
cunha marcelo levou o meu cara tava
sátão e viu de tudo mudou
rio o réu polícia
será que só enriquece policial em são
paulo contra quem filme all também de
internacional e de pentecostes em bonn
oeste dentro hoje é estrelado por tom
cavalcante é o prato e jerson domingos
desculpa e serra
o tiro limpa e chuta sem forro bruno de
luca
lá ela deixou do que assegure a margem
segura
[Música]
é verdade que vai ter show do fábio
júnior
mandei a minha porque você não cantou
enrosca esparsas papai noel às 16 horas
em breve nos cinemas